so when I when I hit all right I have
that same fart go on into the ground do
it here and of course as he's pushing
I'm in the cross the push by I'm not
nothing
hey he's taking these energy in the
ground
don't turn your toes out oh and I'm
gonna do that as if I was doing that
strike so my hands not in the right
hands to the ground I'm going to just do
my heart
[Music]
it's not it's not there are just
different ways of using force right
generating force and using force they
have their purposes they do different
things but one thing that you probably
noticed is around at this midpoint you
get pretty good same reaction around
ground shoulders right this is a little
zone right here you see that same thing
with waist it's at the next here where
you start to have a different effect
right what effect is on the arm one you
your waist tends to break right so
you're going over here and his energy
pulls his weight right because you threw
it over there and so if you look at my
posture and when I turn my waist to get
rid of that break then my whole body is
starting to follow that way okay so
that's why we need when you guys go over
here and every time you have to snap
into justice one more move one more beat
you're behind them right so what the
other one is doing it kind of throws and
when you hit that cone the ground path
is taking taking over
I need extra room right then everything
goes
[Music]
so because I'm grounded and I'm not off
bouncing I'm not broken I'm free to move
[Music]
so when when I'm doing this strike right
I'm working within my knee hip foot
relationship so when this back knee
caves like this right then you can feel
that right though there's a hole in
space opens up there okay so you have to
watch so you can't go like this
you see my knee you see my niece go
ahead and push so I keep my foot knee
hip relationship if I can't keep it
let's say you're like I need I needed it
to go out there you know what I mean
well you have to just change the whole
thing so maybe that goes here I don't go
I need him over there like this
[Music]
all those little delays because you're
actually off-balance because you're just
using your arms there you off-balance
again now you have to adjust and then
you can go
so all those brakes that's where they're
gonna counter you okay keep going so
what's going to become your front knee
buckles in high they got a heavier
person yo your mass is gonna be
displaced to try it again
so let's just let's throw with our right
arm so your right knee as you go don't
let it come out of Whitney hip alignment
[Music]
his arms
that was arms and so we had the effect
right you you're basically swinging a
centrifugal energy around you there's
going to be an hour pulling force so you
have the opposite effect you need to
have an inward pulling force so it's
because you're the weight there's a
weight to you okay so when you have an
external or how we're pulling force it
will pull you off balance okay keep
going
[Music]
turn your hands where mine were stick
with the opening yeah like that last 45%
you just turns into your arms better
that's it
and breathe down now when you held your
breath
and that made you top-heavy down
I keep that right
it's when it's when I start messing it
up so here my knees outside but so too
is my back knee okay so I can do it with
body movement to keep it yeah body
movement I can do it with my Center
movement because I'm gonna keep my knee
and hip within the width of that if I
need more room like I said I can turn my
hips whoa Gary's getting past me do you
see that and the back knee is getting
out of foot alignment so I'm going to
turn my hips and I'm back in them back
in the line
but how does my foot turn you guys are
trying to aim it okay this is gonna look
like a 45-degree angle and then you turn
your foot at a 45-degree no Mike as my
as my hips turn because I have this
relationship I can feel it pull on my
foot I feel it in my hips turn pulls
might lose my feet you see that it's
this part my heart turns lose my key not
like this you see the difference Hey
so my hottest turning turns my foot
hottest turning alright go
my heart turns turns my foot I'm not
doing this it's not I have the
relationship it is my hips turn my body
will turn turn my legs
[Music]
you can see the knee hip foot alignment
is always being compromised and it
requires little adjustments little beats
little compromises and tactics - there's
one not enough entry you can't you can't
move forward balance their arms swing to
hold it try to hold your knee foot hip
alignment go a little slower these time
again so the hip moved in the foot
stayed still because the foot is
separate in your body mind another foot
lead try it again
[Music]
enter deeper he held it at the end that
was good do the same side hold it
together
good hold it keep it and enter with it
they're weird okay